es momento de hablar de salud nos
acompañan en el estudio ya más Romero
sala bienvenida Gracias Rosa bienvenido
tú también mar empezamos con un tema Que
supongo que sorprenderá bastante esa
personas porque es una empresa muy
conocido biontech que enfrenta su primer
día de juicio en Alemania por los
efectos secundarios de la vacuna de
covid-19 Sí eso qué tanto tiempo nos
ocupó hablando también aquí no en los
informativos de esos efectos secundarios
ahora se está traduciendo en un enredo
judicial para biomtech que hoy tiene la
primera audiencia por la denuncia de una
mujer que además desde el anonimato
denuncia a la farmacéutica recordemos
que la vacuna que desarrollaron es la
que desarrollaron con pfizer es una de
las más aplicadas en todo el mundo y
especialmente en Alemania y en Europa
Alemania es donde está sucediendo el
juicio como decíamos no se juegan unos
150.000 euros que son unos 161 mil
dólares de hecho un poco más y como
decíamos la mujer denunciaba que sintió
dolor corporal extre inflamadas fatiga y
trastornos de sueño a raíz de la vacuna
la firma de abogados además que
representa a esta mujer asegura que
maneja además de esto unos 250 casos en
total de personas que están planteándose
o buscando denunciar a farmacéuticas por
los efectos secundarios del covid-19
Según la ley alemana sería culpable en
el caso de que los efectos secundarios
sean desproporcionados Respecto a los
beneficios que aporta el medicamento o
si la información de la etiqueta o de la
prescripción digamos está mal y en este
sentido la agencia europea del
medicamento lo que hizo fue recordar no
que todas estas empresas que
farmacéuticas que desarrollaron las
vacunas del covid estuvieron bajo un
escrutinio exhaustivo de
entregar informes mensuales detallados
sobre la seguridad cada mes revisaron
hasta 56 casos en este caso hasta
diciembre de 2022 así que bueno es
importante también traer esto para
contextualizar no que realmente han sido
revisadas las vacunas de covid mes a mes
su seguridad desde que empezó la
pandemia claro Omar porque se fue
finalmente no un proceso muy rápido que
merecía
muchísimo escrutinio le preguntó
precisamente Cuáles son los efectos
conocidos probados digamos los que
figuraban En las etiquetas imagino no
Exacto esto es que digamos como decías
figuran En las etiquetas que están
reconocidos y estudiados los más
habituales son algunos que seguro que
conocemos todos como el dolor de cabeza
la fiebre el dolor muscular o la fatiga
no un poco menos habituales pero igual
dentro de los llamados comunes están
también el insomnio las náuseas como
vemos algunos de estos coinciden con los
que la mujer denuncia y en general duran
muy pocos días después de la inyección
hasta unos dos días de malestar en los
efectos secundarios raros está la
anafilaxis que es una reacción alérgica
severa que ha sido registrada en
poquísimos Casos y luego también la
miocarditis o pericarditis que es la
inflamación del corazón o de la membrana
que rodea el corazón
encontró que sucedía más sobre todo en
hombres menores de 40 años después de la
segunda dosis de la segunda inyección y
se han registrado según datos entre
Estados Unidos en este caso unos 80
casos por un millón de dosis
administradas es decir que es un caso
también bastante raro Nosotros también
buscamos los datos en el caso de la Ema
de la agencia europea del medicamento de
Cuántos registros de efectos secundarios
han recibido por las vacunas de covid-19
y vemos que han sido 1,7 millones de
reportes espontáneos es decir que
trabajadores de la salud o pacientes han
reportado este efecto secundario todo
esto en una aproximadamente mil millones
de dosis es decir terminan una
proporción de 0,2 casos por 100 dosis
administradas entonces bueno como vemos
en todos los casos son bastante bajos y
en este sentido esa balanza equilibrio
beneficio Tendremos que ver qué sucede
en el juicio pero en este caso parece
que se sigue inclinando mucho hacia el
lado de los beneficios No pues eso
esperamos mar y seguro que usted nos
traerá todas las actualidades un poco la
actualización de este proceso pero
cambiamos de tema porque la Ops publicó
un estudio sobre Salud Mental en América
Latina que nos dice de nuestra región
este reporte sí es un informe que deja
muchos datos de hechos en la región
americana es decir que también incluye
Estados Unidos y Canadá según la
división que hace la Organización
Mundial de la Salud de las zonas del
mundo no destacamos un dato Bueno un
dato malo el malo empecemos por ahí es
que el 80% de las personas que viven con
un trastorno de Salud Mental grave no
tiene acceso a tratamientos estás en
tratamientos algo que nos muestra no
este problema para acceder precisamente
a soluciones a curas a tratamientos en
el caso de la Salud Mental en la región
pero en el mismo sentido también es
cierto que desde 2020 un momento en el
que muchos servicios se vieron
interrumpidos y especialmente Los de la
Salud Mental a raíz de la pandemia de
covid-19 estas interrupciones se han
reducido en un 75%
en estos tres años es decir que estamos
volviendo digamos a la normalidad en
términos de atención y de servicios a la
Salud Mental en los sistemas de salud
pública por supuesto destacar también
que es un problema de dimensiones no muy
importantes los trastornos depresivos y
de ansiedad en todo el continente
americano son la tercera y la cuarta
causa de discapacidad en la región algo
que nos muestra no que hay muchas
personas las que están afectadas por
esto Exacto Mary precisamente no es
importante saber que hay muchas personas
en la misma situación para pensar en
soluciones globales estructurales por
eso le pregunto Cuáles son las
propuestas a que hace la organización
Pues precisamente el director de la
organización Panamericana de la salud la
rama americana de la OMS hablaba de eso
escuchémoslo
un sistema de atención inadecuado que
frecuentemente prioriza el internamiento
la decisión cuenta con la mayor duración
media de internamiento de la
federaciones
cuando la gran mayoría de los problemas
de Salud Mental podrían decir con una
atención basada en la comunidad una
atención no que no dependa únicamente de
la hospitalización especialmente en los
problemas más graves y que según la Ops
se consigue principalmente con más
financiación es el primer llamado que se
hace que se financian a los sistemas de
salud especialmente en atención a Salud
Mental como debe ser porque es un
problema muy invisibilizado que ha
ganado visibilizar últimamente pero muy
invisibilizado entonces pues que muchas
veces sube precisamente de esta
infrafinanciación no también tener en
cuenta otra de las recomendaciones de la
organización Panamericana de la salud el
racismo y las desigualdades de género
como determinantes de la Salud Mental
que es algo que venimos diciendo pero
que es hora no que se entienda y se
englobe también dentro de los planes
nacional de cada gobierno para entender
eso Y por supuesto también enfocarnos en
la prevención la prevención es básica
para que cosas que son puntuales no se
cronifiquen que luego es cuando los
problemas se hacen más grandes así que
bueno Estas son las guías hay más que se
pueden consultar en su página web para
tratar de mejorar esta situación bueno
Mari como usted también siempre nos
recomienda no pensar la Salud Mental
precisamente como una cuestión social y
no como una patología exclusivamente
individual así de Rosa Muchas gracias
mar nos vemos mañana con más salud aquí
en directo hasta mañana
[Música]